ich möchte anfang bei der frage was in
polen los ist das ist das thema der
woche es ist das thema des monats wir
haben die flüchtlinge dort an der grenze
in den vergangenen tagen gesehen und
neben vielen kindern die wir hier aus
sehen gibt es auch diejenigen die wütend
auf grenzer dort losgegangen sind ganz
unabhängig von der situation finde ich
dass wir die polen dort nicht im stich
lassen dürfen und dass das was
eu-kommissionspräsident ursula von der
leyen gemacht hat zu beginn der krise
nämlich auszuschließen dass man dort an
der grenze helfen will dass man einen
zaun mit eu mitteln nicht finanzieren
will finde ich das falsch denn damit hat
man das signal gesetzt dass die polen
alleine gelassen werden dass im stich
gelassen werden mit dem was dort
passiert denn wir brauchen eine
außengrenze die funktioniert wenn wir
eine schengen grenze wenn wir dort keine
grenzkontrollen haben wollen diese
grenze muss es geben diese grenze
braucht ist und polen hat auch gezeigt
so brutal diese bilder aus gesehen haben
das ist möglich ist am ende eine grenzen
zu schützen jetzt bleibt die frage was
passiert dort mit den flüchtlingen und
da ist aus meiner sicht wiederum eine
humanitäre geste gefragte natürlich
dürfen wir diese flüchtlinge nicht im
stich lassen und der richtige weg ist
der der gerade besprochen wurde nämlich
zum einen dass es sanktionen gibt gegen
die flug airlines und zum anderen aber
auch druck auf lukas schenkel das den
flüchtlingen dort in dem waldgebiet
geholfen wird dass sie möglicherweise
wieder nach kurdistan wo die meisten
herkommen zurückgeflogen werden ich
persönlich kenne einen der dort war das
war mein fahrer in der zeit als ich in
der bill & mossul berichtet habe und da
haben wir freunde erzählt er ist aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen dort
hingegangen weil er gesagt hat so kommt
er am leichtesten nach deutschland
erstmalig die forderung komplett richtig
dass wir die polen nicht im stich lassen
sollten an der grenze ich frage mich nur
wie können wir diesen druck auf
lukaschenko ausüben du bist da der
experte was könnte man tun also ich
glaube das ist das erste mal gezeigt hat
dass sanktionen funktionieren können
deren überraschender weise hat ja
turkish airlines das eingestellt und
gleichzeitig bellaria die belarussische
airline die jetzt auch keine irak ist
syrer mehr transportiert am ende
funktioniert auch da ist wieder nur über
putin also da weiter druck zu machen und
die grenze zu sichern und zu zeigen hier
kommt keiner durch aber da am ende
funktioniert ist nur wieder putin zudem
haben wir zum beispiel wir jetzt nicht
das beste verhältnis also frau merkel
besuche den zwar nimmt auch ein
blumenstrauß von ihm entgegen aber ich
frage mich wie man das lösen kann also
ich schaue mir die bilder an empfinde
auch großes mitleid muss ich sagen für
die flüchtlinge und ich stehe immer
wieder vor der frage was kann denn jetzt
passieren ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
die sanktion wirklich was bringen ich
hoffe ihr entschuldigt mein wort
wortlaut ich habe das gefühl der
lukaschenko ist völlig verrückt geworden
und wie geht man gegen einen
wahnsinnigen wo sie körper reagiert man
da ja gut ich meine ich glaube ich dass
lukaschenko ein wahnsinniger ist gut den
sagt kein wort zu ingres sind einfach
eiskaut nach zyniker und was sie jetzt
machen ist im prinzip die versuchen die
eu maximal zu beschädigen sie versuchen
mit seiner nichte oder in die weichteile
zu haben sie missbrauchen diese
migranten die sich ja noch ein fliegen
die werden richtig gehend eingeflogen
das ist ein migrations krieg der kommt
die ursache ist natürlich dass die
europäische union jetzt jahrelang
provoziert hat auch gegen die russen und
ich habe immer gesagt wenn du den bären
reizt wenn du den bären reizt dann
reicht es eben nicht wenn du nicht mal
ne weile in der hosentasche hast dann
musst du natürlich etwas haben um den
rücken geschlagen jetzt zurück und jetzt
muss man einfach aufpassen dass man
unter dem druck dieser emotionalen
bilder nicht das falsch gemacht die
polen werden ja da fürchterlich
abgestraft weil sie die grenze sichern
was eigentlich richtig ist wo kann ich
einfach kommen aber von hinten werden ja
diese armen menschen die da eingeflogen
wurden jetzt bedrängt von den russen
dich geht in richtung paul ronzheimer
ich glaube jetzt muss die eu versucht
diese leute irgendwie wieder nach
zurückzuführen zurück zu fahren das ist
es gab mal ein beispiel wenn ich das
noch sagen darf anfangs der 90er jahre
ist doch albanien zusammengebrochen das
sind plötzlich alle aufbauen
hunderttausende von aufbauen nach
italien gefahren da haben die italiener
diese arbeit aufgenommen haben sie in
fußballstadien versammelt dann hat man
die sofort wieder auf schiffe gesetzt
und zurück gefahren auf albanien das
wäre im grunde eine lösung aber ich
befürchte das wird nicht so lassen weil
der lukaschenko möchte die eu gespalten
er möchte diese migranten in die eu
hineindrücken um hier ein möglichst
großes haus einzurichten und das darf
man nicht passieren dass das darf man
nicht zulassen kann in butzbach genau an
meine frage wenn wir jetzt den fall
nehmen es wird immer kälter dort an der
grenze können wir das als eu am ende
hinnehmen zu sagen ja gut ob er jetzt
jemand erfriert oder nicht aber wir
müssen draußen ich glaube das erst mal
die komplett falsche fragestellung ich
würde gern mal auf einen deutschen frau
gerne auf dem ausgangspunkt zurück ja
was wird wie inwieweit überhaupt
gefordert sind das zu tun ich habe eine
ganz klare haltung zu was gerade
passiert ist das nicht holen sondern die
ganze eu wird gerade an dieser grenze
erpresst das muss man sich klar machen
deswegen sind wir alle gleichermaßen
gefordert und es ist doch auch ganz klar
unsere rolle in deutschland was uns
dabei zukommt wir sehen es doch jeden
aber wir sehen die bilder auf wir wissen
was das ziel der menschen ist das ziel
ist ganz klar deutschland sich stehen an
der grenze klar es werden meistens
frauen und kinder gezeigt das ist aber
nicht ehrlich wir müssen da einfach
aufrichtig genug sein es sind 95 prozent
männer es sind junge männer die an
dieser grenze stehen und nur an einzige
kommen haben und dass er in deutschland
wie kommen sie auf 5 90 prozent gibt es
eine statistik zum der offizieller ich
glaube ich dass eine offizielle
statistik gibt es gibt aber gut also
wieder auf über 90 absolut wir schon
sagt für panikmache auch in der
gesellschaft ich also die firma 90
prozent ist eine schätzung von dir
absolut und panikmache ist das
allerletzte was wir gerade brauchen ganz
im gegenteil keine emotionalisierung
aber auch keine mobilisierung uns auf
deine frage einzugehen auch kein
aktionismus sondern ganz im gegenteil
nachhaltig ausgerichtete pläne um auch
aber kein aktionismus ist ja leicht
gesagt wir stehen da nicht da geht es in
die minustemperaturen auf der einen
seite lukaschenko soldaten auf der
anderen seite polnische grenze verriet
können wir das aushalten also das ist
eine wundervolle theoretische
fragestellung die wir da haben dies
nicht spielen theoretisch doch ganz
gewiss ist die spiel theoretisch weil
das letztlich 1 eine andere seite dazu
bewegen kann etwas zu tun weil sie
eigentlich gar nicht tun will das ist
nämlich die methode sie selber in eine
position zu bringen die so schlecht ist
das ein anderer nicht zu sehen kann und
das dulden kann und auf die art und
weise werden wir sozusagen wie sie
gerade gesagt haben in den weichteilen
gepackt das ist genau die stelle an dem
wir stärksten angreifbar sind und ich
glaube nicht dass wir das durchstehen
können und dies auch nicht durchstehen
sollten also das ist schon ein schachzug
gewesen der verdammt clever also meinen
sie wir sollten diejenigen die jetzt
dort sind das sind rund 2000 menschen
die meisten aus kurdistan man muss noch
mal sagen in kurdistan herrscht momentan
kein krieg zumindest im irakischen teil
im syrischen teil schon müssten wir die
übernehmen ich sage nicht dass wir das
tun sollen und ich sage dass ich es
wahrscheinlich tun müssen am ende weil
das ist wie wir auf dem schachbrett jaja
gibt es auch zwischen der position bei
dem man sagen das will man eigentlich
nicht macht muss es aus irgendwelchen
anderen grund und trotzdem machen aber
genau so einer situation im augenblick
rein manövriert worden und von von wegen
nicht rational also das stimmt nicht das
ist eine völlig rationale
verhaltensweise des gegenspielers und
der hat einfach genau dafür gesorgt dass
in einer position sind aus der wir
eigentlich nicht mehr rauskommen können
also nicht dass wir das wollen ob es
sich auch natürlich einen lukaschenko
putin habe natürlich einen fehler
gemacht sie spekulieren darauf dass die
europäische union die 2015 bereit ist im
prinzip die ganze dekoration gesetze
über den haufen zu werfen die grenzen zu
öffnen naja sagen wir jetzt aber polen
wenn wir jetzt einfach die grenzen
bewacht was sie machen müssten gemäß den
schengen verträgen und gemäss dem dublin
abkommen müssten sie haben wir müssen
hier die grenzen ab und weil diese leute
die dort an der grenze stehen sind per
definitionem keine flüchtlinge nach
genfer konvention weil sie in einem aus
sicht des sogenannten friedlich sie
einem sicheren drittstaat sind in von
lukaschenko wenn sich dann leib und
leben so folgt sind da von ihm
eingeflogen wurden dürfen wir also nicht
aufnehmen wenn man die polen darin
unterstützt da möchte ich dann noch
sehen ob dann lukas schenkel tatsächlich
mit diesen migranten so ein horrorspiel
macht und die dann einfach an der grenze
von serben lassen kann also das sage ich
dann noch nicht aber sie wollen und sie
spekulieren darauf dass die eu
zusammenbricht dass das hier reinkommt
dass wir dann ein riesenhaus haben auch
wieder den aufstand sozusagen bestimmte
politische gruppierungen zwar wie 2015
und da darf man einfach den fehler nicht
brauchen dass man die eigene
rechtsordnung in der eu wieder so
schnell suspendiert unter dem druck der
emotionen und diese zynischen macht
schauspieler darin in moskau und in
minsk ich möchte euch ein beispiel sind
ich habe den fahrer genannt den ich
kenne der eben aus erbil kommt und da
erzählt mir die freunde mit dem habe ich
über jahre zusammengearbeitet der hatte
ein lkw der ist taxi gefahren der hat
okay verdient dort in der region also
konnte normal leben und dem wurde dieser
weg geöffnet und kann sie jetzt nach
deutschland kommen und da geht's dir
viel besser und dann hat er alles
verkauft was er hatte sein ganzes geld
genommen und habe diesen weg angetreten
und war jetzt seit zwei drei monaten
dort ist offenbar nicht rübergekommen
aber die menschen werden ja bewusst
ausgenutzt und da wird über social media
werbung gemacht so zu sagen dass man
dann der industrie die werden
industriell als kunden angeworben wenn
ich nur einen punkt setzen aber wir
hatten dieses problem in der schweiz
2006 nicht so bekommt und zwar mit
nigerianer die sind genauso industriell
richtig angeworben wurden in die schweiz
eingeflogen worden und was hat damals
die regierung gemacht wenn der schmerz
ich gesagt okay die sind jetzt hier den
hat man das blaue vom himmel versprochen
wir führen die jetzt wieder zurück
diesen diese kunden diese schlepper
industrieböden sowie bringen die zurück
nach nigeria und die 10.000 dollar die
sie bezahlt haben die haben sie nichts
bezahlt und so konnte man diese
schlepper industrie die kunden entziehen
und dadurch die schlepper industrie
schädigen wenn du sie auf nimmst dann
belohnt so lukaschenko darum belohnt du
putin dann ist ihr dreckiges spiel ich
kann sich darum das sagen aber die eu
ist eben auch schon an diesen dreckigen
spiel durch dieses herumgezeigt oder das
ist dies mit dem bären reizen sind eben
selber von der leyen aber sie darf jetzt
da nicht in diesen triumph denen
gewähren den beiden zu nicken im osten
liegt
aber sowas von